hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and right now this is your opportunity
to ask me anything this is your
opportunity to ask me questions
about property investment to help you
specifically
with your journey as an entrepreneur so
get
commenting below comment below and then
i'll do my very best to answer your
questions
on next week's q and a sunday however
right now i'm going to be answering some
questions from last week's video
so let's see what we've got by the way
if you enjoy my channel please do me a
massive favor
smash the like button also subscribe
turn the notification bell on
so last week with lots and lots of
questions we had a question from a guy
called dan
dan sanj said in my quest
to become financially free i'm finding
to get a good
buy to let mortgage a lot of mortgage
lenders require a minimum employment
income
of 25 000 pounds
how can i become financially free if
mortgage lenders
have this requirement uh
dan i feel you're paying uh great
question so i assume you're earning less
than 25 000 pounds a year hence why
you're struggling to get a mortgage
there are a lot of lenders out there
that should lend to you
on a mortgage where your earning is less
than 25 grand so
first thing i would say is rather than
going to a bank
or going to a lender like santander or
halifax and saying hey can you give me a
mortgage
you should find an independent mortgage
advisor who is a broker
and when i say independent that means
that they're not a mortgage advisor that
work for
lloyds they're an independent mortgage
broker
who has whole of market access so they
can look at your situation down and they
can say right
this is your earning this is your
situation or your first time buyer and
unbanned
and then they can then find a a
suitable lender for you now if you do
that and you still can't get any finance
then it might be worth doing one of a
couple of things you could firstly
you could bring somebody on
the mortgage with you this could be
known as something like
tenants in common if you speak to your
mortgage broker about what tenants in
common is
he'll explain or she'll explain how that
works you could
join venture with somebody so there are
lots of or you could
do what i did dude i was 17 when i got
my first house do you think i could get
a mortgage
no so what did i do i found a family
member who could host the property for
me
in their name and then when i got to a
suitable age in the future
we exchanged it now to be fair it was a
bit of a nightmare
exchanging it over into my name which
took years
but there's always a solution so i hope
that helps
great question anything else you need
for me hit me up
on instagram comment below and i'll do
my best to help
okay next dpg
is this is crazy because dpg is the dude
behind the camera
and it's funny because he's my
videographer always asking me questions
i'm like
i'm like dude that's a really good
question you know what
on sunday at 7pm there's this really
cool
thing called q a sunday i say it's all
my video reverse so uh darwin it's
actually got a question to see
let's see what we got how do you split
50 50 with an investor on a brr
ah um okay
so how do you split 50 50 with an
investor on a brl so i assume
what darwin is talking about you can
tell me if i'm wrong because you're
right behind the camera
is if you've got an investor that wants
to put the money in
and you're finding the deal and doing
all the work
how do you split it how do you structure
it is that correct
okay cool so the first thing i would say
is um
if you've got an investor that's
prepared to put the money in and they're
saying look i've got the money i want to
put it in
the way i would probably structure it is
i would set up a company
i would have a company i would set the
company up in both
your name and in the investor's name go
50 50
and then i would get the investor to
loan the money
to the company so let's say me and you
want to do a deal
right and you go hey samuel i found a
deal i'm going to manage it i'm going to
do everything
but samuel can you put your money in it
what we would do is
set up a company called samuel and d
estates
i would put my hundred thousand pounds
or whatever it was needed
into the company as a loan it's my money
i'm going to get that money back it's
loaned to the company
the company which is 50 50 owned by us
buys the property
pushes the value up refinances
then pay me back but the company keeps
the property and the company keeps the
rent which is 50 50.
makes sense awesome all right next
martin townsend says i love your content
and the crash course
i went to was great good i'm glad you
enjoyed the crash course well if you've
not been to the crash course little plug
it's free i'm not even selling it's not
even an advert
it's just it's free it's on the house so
come on down to the property investors
crash course i'll be there personally
i'd love to meet you i'd love to shake
your hand
maybe give you an elbow an elbow pump or
something um
and help you in property okay martin
says um i have a six bed hmo
my letting agent is taking a long time
to fill the sixth room
is there anything i could do to speed up
getting it filled also what's your
opinion on 15
deposits compared to 25. okay to get the
sixth room field if you've got five
people in there already
guaranteed one of those tenants will
know somebody so i would just say
to all the tenants i do a refer a friend
skin
hey five tenants if you can put somebody
in i'll give you a hundred pound
referral thank you fee guaranteed that
room will get filled real fast
my opinion on 15 deposits compared to 25
i think it's great
the less money you put down the better
because you're leveraging more of the
bank's money which means your return on
investment is higher
richard harrington seen some of your
videos and you seem to suggest you
bought a property without physically
viewing
it that is correct sir it looks better
than the photos do you recommend this
isn't it a risk of what sort of things
you should be looking out for if buying
when viewing
all right richard i don't think
generally
it's good practice to buy stuff without
looking at it i have done that many
times to be fair
um the reason i've done that is because
i've bought a lot of properties and if i
had to physically go and view every
single property that i bought
um i mean it would just take a long time
especially as
some of the houses that i've bought over
the years have been like miles away from
my house
however okay whenever i've done that
i've
always had a surveyor go to the property
an independent building surveyor to do a
full survey of the house
i've also had a letting agent go and
talk to me about the area and the
rentability
so it's not that no one's been it's just
that i haven't been
but i've sent trusted people to go on my
behalf
so generally speaking go to your house
view before you buy it 100
or if you're buying lots of houses and
you physically haven't got the time to
do that
then make sure that you're getting a
survey on the property and and and hope
that helps
jack what do you do with the profits
inside your businesses
do you constantly reinvest and buy
properties with the money
pay yourself etc um jack what i do with
the money
um firstly i pay myself a salary
so i pay myself a wage from
my property company so all the money
that
my property company is making and all my
other companies are making
i just pay myself a small wage well
it's all relative small in comparison to
how much money is being made
the profits generally correct the
profits get reinvested
back into the business back into
investing in properties the profits go
to my charity my samuel leeds foundation
charity
and then um yeah that's it but it's
really important to pay yourself
first before anyone else gets paid
before the tax man gets paid
before the bills get paid even before
the staff get paid i get paid i get paid
first
i'm paying myself first um
so i mean there have been times when i
haven't been able to pay myself when
times have been really really tough
in the business um even recently
you know when we when we went into
lockdown in april oh my goodness
um i kind of broke my own rule because i
always say pay yourself first pay
yourself first
but it was times were tough i had a
ridiculous overheads
expenses um and and it was just like
when everything was getting down valued
and i made a loss on a bunch of
properties
um we had loads of events booked
expensive events
it costs anywhere between 20 and 100
grand
to put a big event on and we had lots of
events that we committed to paying for
um it was really rough and i actually
didn't i actually took a hit
and for for a period of time i didn't
pay myself a wage which was really
it was a really strange time and i have
as well when i started out in property
when i was like 17
i didn't pay myself any money every
penny i earned went straight back into
petrol to go and view houses to
networking events to hotels to you know
everything i didn't get paid for ages
but so i think it does depend but
generally speaking the structure of my
business is i pay myself a wage
the wage doesn't change the profits get
reinvested back into the business
back into property the bricks and mortar
property itself
to build and grow and then also to
charity so
that's generally the case okay goku
black
i found a one bedroom flat in london for
196 thousand pounds do you think that's
a good price
it's kind of hard for me to say whether
it's a good price without knowing
anything about the flat
i mean it sounds like a reasonably cheap
price for a flat in london but i
wouldn't be able to say it depends on
what the
area of london is on the condition of
the flat
it depends on lots of things but
ultimately it's not about whether it's a
good price it's about whether it's going
to give you a good return on investment
if you're buying it as an investment you
want to say well if i buy it for 196
what's the rent going to be what's the
return going to be
but make sure you do serious due
diligence before buying
any property you know you need to know
what are the other properties in the
in the apartment block selling for so if
it's on for 196 if it's a flat
presumably
there's probably lots of other flats
within the block so you want to be able
to you need to go to rightmove
look at the house prices type the
postcode in
it's all free you can do this online for
free and then
look and see what else is selling in
that block and if there's lots of stuff
selling for like 250 300 250
300 300 350 and then you've got this for
196
then yeah maybe it's a great deal but do
you research and make sure the return on
investment is good
okay last question if you've got
questions don't forget comment below
peter s hey big sam
not quite sure how i uh how i feel about
being called big sam
but that's okay let's see what you got
to say i have seven buy to let
properties currently giving me around
three thousand pounds net profit per
month
so i am financially free with a lot of
help from your videos oh that's good
i'm i'm going to let you off now i'm
going to let you off um calling me big
sound but
um some of the properties are rented by
the room and some are single let's
how do i grow the portfolio now
how do i finance the growth should i
approach my bank for asset lending
facilities
can you briefly break down how you grew
your portfolio from the position
i'm into where you are now thanks buddy
you're awesome okay peter great question
so it sounds to me like you probably are
a decent earner you've probably got a
good job or a business and you're making
decent money
but you want to invest in properties it
sounds similar you had some savings
and you've now invested all of your
savings into property
hmos single let's give you a really good
return on investment hence why you're
making
three thousand pounds plus a month
you're now financially free
congratulations
the problem is now you are out of money
so what could you do well you could
save up more money take the three grand
a month for save and save and save it
and just slowly
grow your portfolio the problems with
that is that's a really really slow way
of doing it
and it's just not smart what i did
was i did a couple of things number one
is i
packaged and sold other deals to other
people
so i got my a lot of people are in your
situation peter they buy some houses
it's all good but then they run out of
money and they're like oh now i have to
wait for the properties to go up in
value before i can refinance
going to the bank and asking them for a
loan to invest in property probably
won't work
because when you're investing in
property you're already getting
mortgages
if you're getting a mortgage and then
your bank is lending you the deposit
banks don't really like doing that so
a lot of people in your situation um it
depends on your time and it depends on
i'd love to chat to you a little bit in
person and give you
maybe a blueprint of what you should do
um you've got
a few options you could make more money
by like deal sourcing or something and
then use that money to buy put into
property that's what i did
another thing that i did which you
should probably do is you should
now you've got experience as a landlord
as a property investor
owning hmos you could go hey here's what
i've done here are my properties
and you can start bringing in joint
ventures in on your deals
getting angel investors to finance your
deals and give them a percentage of the
profit
even if you're giving them 50 of the
profit if they're putting all the money
in
if they do that with two deals you've
put in no money and you're making the
same profit as if you did it with one
deal
hope that makes sense so you could joint
venture raise finance from angel
investors
um also you could start filing different
types of deals
so instead of buying properties and
renting them out
you can start filing deals whereby you
buy them and then you add value and then
refinance and that way you're able to
recycle the same pot of money
so if i were you i would use all you've
done all your experience
put together a business proposal find
some investors and get them to
to get lend you a pot of money and use
that pot of money
to recycle using the buy refurbishing
finance strategy
i probably do that but there's so many
different things you could do
lease option agreements that's another
thing you could do
buying properties without using deposits
hope that helps
guys if you've got questions comment
below if you want to meet me at training
get booked on and let's spend some time
together subscribe thanks for watching
i'll see you next time
you